how does the surprise Cameo influence
the costume of the New Black Panther
stick around to find out if you don't
mind spoilers plenty of those ahead
shury's path to becoming the next Black
Panther is not an easy one after
t'challa's off-screen death in the
beginning of black panther wakanda
forever she resists wakandan tradition
for some time despite Queen Ramona's
gentle nudges it's not until she loses
Ramona Neymar's attack on wakanda that
she realizes she has no other option if
she wants to fight back and even then
she has to painstakingly recreate the
genetically engineered version of the
now extinct heart-shaped herb first
however when Sherry actually consumes
the herb and embarks on a Vision Quest
To The ancestral plane her troubles only
increase instead of her mother father or
brother her vision guide is her cousin
in jadaka AKA Eric killmonger Stevens
the antagonist of the first Black
Panther movie you'll never be a true
king
killmonger not so subtly explains
shuri's anger and sorrow have made her
closer to him in spirit than to the more
traditionally Noble members of her
family when she wakes up she is
understandably frustrated with the
nature of her vision initially believing
that her black panther ritual has failed
when sure he finds out that it actually
worked she's still hesitant to tell
Nikia about killmonger even when
directly questioned that's why it might
be surprising that shuri doesn't choose
a t'challa-style black panther helmet
for herself but makes a beeline for a
gold patterned helmet with a design
that's similar to the one killmonger
used to wear as devoted fans know Black
Panther's killmonger is one of the mcu's
most nuanced villains he might be a
dangerous killer and a sworn enemy of
wakanda's royal family but he's also a
victim of a major personal tragedy and
makes some good points about quite a few
things he definitely knows what he's
saying when he tells shuri that the two
are on very similar paths just like
killmonger shuri has lost her last
remaining family member to an
unbelievably powerful ruler of a nation
that has access to vibranium and just
like killmonger shuri is completely
consumed with a request for Revenge
outwardly she rejects killmonger and
refuses to reveal their meeting to
anyone However the fact that she chooses
the killmonger style black panther
helmet almost immediately afterwards
implies that at least on some level she
realizes that her late cousin is correct
when she's discussing her anti-namor
plot which imbari libaku she seems to be
in full killmonger mode planning to take
the fight to the telecon king's Turf and
destroy him personally as you might
notice this is very similar to
killmonger's own approach against
wakanda and t'challa and black panther
I'm gonna check down anyone who would
even think about being loyal to you and
I'm gonna put their ass in the dirt
right next to Zuri fortunately for her
own mental well-being and the lives of
her allies shury's killmonger mode
doesn't last she shakes off the shackles
of her bloodlust after overpowering
Neymar in the desert and seeing a last
moment vision of her mother regaining
her kindness and rationality she accepts
Neymar's surrender and begins her path
towards spiritual healing just like
ramonda wanted to because of this the
movie ends with shuri in a much better
place it's extremely unlikely that
she'll continue to wear killmonger's
colors now that she seems to be truly
embracing her new role as wakanda's
protector as well as her even newer role
as the surprise Aunt to t'challa's son
to song combine this with shuri's habit
of redesigning and tinkering and it's
virtually guaranteed that she'll have
made a cool new black panther costume
the next time we see her if not several
after all a whole bunch of snazzy New
Black Panther costumes wouldn't exactly
hurt Disney's toy sales
movement